let's talk about transgender where you
know the conversation with Disney saying
you know sex ed by third grade and you
know after third grade we do sex ed and
then uh I think Jen sackey yes said if
you want to put up with jensaki said
yesterday about transgender I don't know
if you saw that or not uh uh put uh Jen
saki uh transgender uh yesterday
briefing yeah if you can huh so for news
yeah software news uh it wouldn't be
March 31st go back to it because it was
yesterday it's April 7th I want to say
just type in news yeah uh press brief
impress Arkansas
uh they're not even gonna put it up
there aren't they it's so ridiculous can
you zoom in a little bit to see if we
have it yeah let me let me find it okay
you find it but meanwhile what is your
position with Disney coming out and then
uh uh Disney's saying that 50 of their
characters moving forward within 12
months are going to be part of the lgbtq
community what's your thoughts on that
well Disney's a private company and
Company I mean I'm sorry well I mean
it's not the government okay okay I mean
it's it's the free market as opposed to
government so they can do whatever they
want and their customers can do whatever
they want and I've heard many people say
that we are not going to continue to put
our money into Disney and I don't like
what they're doing uh but can I step
back to the bigger transgender issue
because this is another issue in which I
think both the Democrats and the
Republicans
are basically wrong
on the Republican side many Republicans
uh are saying you know well first of all
people are confusing sex with gender
um and to use uh you know shorthand
method
genders between the ears sex is between
the legs so and yes it is possible and
I'm teaching this in class right now it
is possible to have the genitalia that
do not match because of hormones
it prenatally especially around the
sixth and seventh week so
um the Republicans
um
act as though there's no such thing as
being transgender that you're basically
just cross-dressing which is a different
thing the Democrats on the other hand
act like 25 percent of the population is
transgender now we've got to change all
of our laws I mean it's less than one
percent it's one out of a thousand
people are transgender so
um there is a a sane place in the Middle
where we can say yes a very very small
minority of people are transgender
um
and why do we need to make laws about
that and oh well and see this gets back
to the the don't say gay thing that gets
more into
parents not having Choice over their
schools and I can tell you that before
age 10
. kids are not thinking about any kind
of sex they they don't understand being
attracted to another person
even heterosexual eight-year-olds are
not thinking about heterosexual sex so
why are we teaching why are they
teaching
um
homosexual sex to eight years old to
eight year olds it doesn't make any
sense but instead of having a law what
we need to have are schools that parents
can
um choose to send their kids to in which
the parents decide and I do think that
parents would overwhelmingly say what do
you mean you're teaching my
seven-year-old about homosexual sex
that's just not even on the radar so
jensaki says a sex reassignment surgery
puberty blockers for kids it's best
practice States preventing it will be
held accountable so for you no that's
horrible it is the libertarian position
let the person do whatever they want to
do with their body or you know if a
nine-year-old wants to change their sex
that should be okay what would your
position be with them
it the research is so clear
that you should not do sex reassignment
before age 16 18 at least uh many kids
it it it really can be a phase in fact I
just said that gender dysphoria is about
one out of a thousand the population
some recent polls have shown that two
percent of high school kids think that
they're transgender okay that can't be
right so these are some people who think
they are but they're not and so I
believe that good medicine would win out
in this case that if you go to a medical
doctor who's trained and who has read
the research they're not going to give
you gender reassignment surgery but the
problem we have now is once again the
government is over overstepping and
they're basically telling doctors you
have to do this and and what you know
has gen sake gone to medical school has
she read the research has has Biden read
the research so why do we have people
who are politicians making these
decisions if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]